bootleg cat podcast special guest in
here are mean yes sir thank you for
having me sir welcome sir my brother
how's everything going man you got a lot
more jewelry on I mean
what's this watch here
it's funny I knew when I walked in here
you were gonna make a comment about my
jacket but I took off now well you had a
pretty ridiculous Gucci jacket on that
was very nice yeah I know it's just you
know it was a big puffer jacket it's
cold outside and I was wearing this
short sleeve and I was either gonna wear
that or like a mediocre looking one no
you're like this you got your Messiah on
though yes you're excited for the World
Cup is this like a time of year or time
of every four years you're excited for
yes this is really the only real thing
that I super follow in sports right like
I'm a basketball fan but I can't say I'm
like really following it the way I used
to right after Kobe and everything I
mean you have a King James song though
yeah I love LeBron but of course you
know and I follow it but you know but
soccer is different I was gonna say
because you are Armenian but you grew up
in the Netherlands right yeah I'm not
Argentinian you're not Argentinian but
you like Messi Messi this is just like a
symbol of greatness you know what I mean
it's like a Jordan jersey a Kobe jersey
right you know what I'm saying
um but yeah I grew up in I'm Armenian
but we don't have
I mean we have a team but not in a World
Cup right
um unfortunately maybe one day
um but I grew up in the Netherlands
Amsterdam so and growing up in Europe
like as far as soccer that's like
deep rooted culture you know what I mean
it's different like people here don't
really understand it yet right no for
sure for sure like when when the
country's playing there's nobody outside
you know everyone's like watching it
everyone I'm talking about my mom right
now is watching the Netherlands play
like you know what I mean you guys beat
the US yes we did I'm sorry were you
excited about that yeah I expected it
you know you guys wasn't ready yet even
though the Netherlands this year we're
not as good as we once where usually are
you know we known as the greatest nation
to never win the World Cup that's
interesting a couple times finals always
in the semis quarters but never actually
won
um what's going on
um I feel like we when we talk what is
uh is there anything new going on that
we should get out there with Armenia I
saw recently like Azerbaijan was
stirring [ __ ] up a little bit again yeah
it's like an ongoing conflict you know
what I'm saying um it's still going on
but it's I I believe it's kind of calm
right now
um Russia is trying to like mediate and
[ __ ] but this is like conflict that's
been happening for like 30 years on and
off but then it was quiet for a long
time and then a couple years ago
um really in the middle of the pandemic
right right got like attacked out of
nowhere and you know basically they were
trying to take over well first there was
this piece of land and I won't go too
deep into it because it gets common we
talked about it a bit before yes if this
piece of land called uh artsak
nagorno-karabakh which is like
kind of within Azerbaijan but it's like
it's a Armenian city right yeah and it's
always a fight over that piece of
country and when the USSR broke up they
gave it to Azerbaijan even though it was
Armenian you know what I mean like on
some divide and conquer type [ __ ] Stalin
did that you know right
um so it's ongoing so then there was a
ceasefire then they attacked again and
the thing is like Azerbaijan is backed
by turkey
which there's a whole history there with
the Armenian Genocide and they're like a
powerful country yeah turkey's no no
Schmucks yeah and and compared to
Armenia you know we can use some help
you know what I'm saying how big of a
deal was it I was gonna say because
speaking of the turkey thing like Joe
Biden acknowledging The Armenian
Genocide as the first president to ever
do that how big of a deal is that look
it was a big deal we All For One Day
celebrated and then we heard that Joe
Biden is
giving military aid to like Azerbaijan
or through turkey or whatever you know
what I'm saying so it was kind of like
hey thanks but [ __ ] you that yeah
exactly yeah which you know honestly
that's what we kind of used to at this
point you know what I mean now because
because I was talking to my boy s dot
about this because we were in Detroit
and uh shout out all my people in
Detroit that's like my second home of
course right you've been out there
you've been running around in a sprinter
out there I think yeah they take care of
me over there but there's a lot of um I
don't even want to [ __ ] up the ethnicity
of people that's out there Chaldeans
Chaldeans albanians Chaldeans a lot of
Arabic Middle Eastern right so we went
to a store and the guy was like there's
all this like Middle Eastern candy and
the guy was like oh this is the Turkish
candy bar you should try it and I've I
looked at that stuff
I bought it
he was like as they're like you better
not dog he's like I won't eat that and I
was like I'm gonna try it bro what if
it's fire like nah it's all good like I
threw the candy bar away the thing would
happen like I grew up in Amsterdam right
it was almost no Armenians I didn't have
a single Armenian friend growing up
um and I lived there till I was 18 and
it was a lot of Turkish people like
Netherlands Germany
so automatically you know you have
friends that have basketball teammates
and [ __ ] like that and they didn't even
know about this they don't understand
it's not it's not about the Turkish
people it's all love you know what I
mean it's about the government but we
don't support [ __ ] that's like made in
Turkey you know what I mean if I see
something that like Zara that says made
in Turkey I'm saying Zara because
they're known for having [ __ ] in Turkey
right
but you'll you do you know Turkish
people who sympathize with what happened
to Armenia yeah I don't I don't really
know a lot of Turkish people personally
now right you know what I'm saying when
I was a kid yeah so I don't really know
but yeah you see people come along along
your timeline like I always wondering
that like if there's like some kids in
Azerbaijan it's like our country's
[ __ ] up no absolutely yeah
absolutely have people like that but
it's also they didn't really have a
freedom of speech and like the the media
whatever journalists again locked up if
they if you know what I mean it's that
kind of country some Russia type [ __ ]
exactly you can't just talk about you
know against the government like Iran
right now there's like a rapper in Iran
that's like lots more like you know what
I mean Iran's [ __ ] wild and they want
to give him like the death penalty I saw
that they were trying to like uh murder
like 15 000 protesters yeah insane it's
insane man shout out to all my people in
Iran for real hey what up y'all we gotta
stop the interview real quick to tell
you about our family at my bookie man
it's my favorite time of the year we got
World Cup NBA and NFL football going on
at the same time there's so many
opportunities for you to make some money
all you got to do is go to my bookie
right now use the promo code bootleg
when you sign up for a new account
they're going to match your first
deposit up to a thousand dollars that
means you go to my bookie you put in 500
bucks for your first deposit using that
promo code bootleg they're gonna give
you another 500 to gamble with for free
free money you could put that on
whatever's going on this weekend in
football
uh maybe you want a better future who
you think's gonna win the Super Bowl
maybe you want to do a future on the
World Cup who do you think is going to
win the World Cup if you're trying to
NBA championship maybe you want to bet
Luca doncic is going to score between 31
and 35 points tonight whatever it is you
can gamble on it at my bookie and
they're giving you free money if you
[ __ ] with that promo code bootleg trust
me man I've been getting this money now
I'm not saying that you're gonna win
like me because you know I got the
[ __ ] picks but if you love
sports and you love to make money
gambling on Sports go to my bookie right
now that's my bookie use the promo code
bootleg and they're going to match your
first deposit up to a thousand dollars
let's get back to the interview uh
you've been super so I feel like for so
long you were just sitting on a bunch of
music and every time I'd see you you'd
play me [ __ ] I'd go when are you gonna
put some [ __ ] out yes you've been on
well you've been on a tear you've been
putting out singles you obviously
dropped the project with burn yep um
that did really well uh you've been
working with everybody from burner to
Davies to
Jeremiah to [ __ ] uh goddamn French
Montana I mean we could go on and on
um
you got a new mixtape coming out yeah so
um like you said I've been working on a
lot of music this mixtape dropping on
the 16th uh me and Justin credible got
together
um really it started with him you know
he started doing like mixtapes on some
old you know what DJ Clue type of [ __ ]
he wanted to kind of get in the music
side of things
earlier this year he put out this
project called hunger flow and he hit me
for like you know I mean I did like a
little freestyle joint on there and then
I saw he's working on a second one and I
had this song called 10 rap Commandments
I shot it to him like yo if you want to
use it you know I mean and he loved it
he put it on his [ __ ] and then we were
just talking he's like yo we should do
more [ __ ] together you know and I saw he
did a he did a tape with the Russell
which was really like his first one like
that you know I mean with like one
artist
it was called just incredible presents
La Russell I'm like yo let's go Justin
credible presents armeen I have a lot of
music so we put put a really dope
project together on dsps or is it like
yeah yeah it's not like on some sound
[ __ ] yeah no there's no freestyles on
famous beats or anything like that yeah
we can't do that now all original I mean
[ __ ] people are doing it yeah I don't
know why but they are yes it's not the
wave like yeah you could do it put it on
YouTube SoundCloud it just don't reach
as many people you know what I mean like
I feel like I made that mistake in the
past you know I mean winner uh the nas
you have some Nas feet Feature Feature
work yes I do when is the Nazis yeah I
feel like I know I've been talking about
it I've heard the songs yes you have um
because I felt like two songs right I'm
not crazy no no you crazy it's one it is
just one okay let's not blow it up too
much I probably you know five songs it
was I'm thinking never mind someone else
I know has two now songs oh I want to
know it was it was belly because with
nas in the weekend
yeah but you have but you have a great
my brother belly you have a great Nas
record bro my Nas record is ridiculous
I'm not gonna lie and um
yeah the thing is so I started working
with Scott Storage on this whole project
and you know we put some joints out like
you said the one with Jeremiah which was
called King James we've got a it's great
yeah great [ __ ] a lot of love yeah I got
I got synced on ESPN I dropped the one
with French earlier this year yeah la
Habibi got a lot of love those were
really like I put them out to kind of
test the waters but like the album is
done now and and it took a little longer
than I expected that's why I had already
you know I didn't hold it in when I went
in the studio when Nas I posted that
[ __ ] the next day yeah and and now we
are here and it's still not out but it's
coming man like now everything is ready
so this just just incredible tape
dropping in the album and then the album
early next year you know I want to start
rolling out of February drop the album
in March yeah I got some big [ __ ] on
there would you and burner do another
clap album I would love to but you know
it was dope yeah the first one is dope
and I yo almost on a daily basis I have
people in my DM asking when I'm doing
another album with Burner just like I
got a lot of burner fans out of this
tour with them yeah and then I work lot
would be real I just dropped a crazy
drawing with be real too but also just
you know he embraced me early on before
all of this so that whole scene that
whole crowd is kind of similar you know
I mean yeah
that smoker crowd so they'd be hitting
me all the time of course I would love
to Berner is my dog but you know he's uh
Forbes cover top five richest you know
what I mean like he busy he's gonna be
number one Richard soon yes he is so he
you know he busy so so hopefully but I
would say in the next two years Bruno's
gonna be richer than Diddy and Jay-Z
yeah I wouldn't be surprised actually
it's going probably 100 yeah it's gonna
happen what up it's bootleg cab man we
gotta stop the interview to tell you
about our good Folks at Bluetooth that's
right fellas if you're dealing with a
little erectile dysfunction yeah dick's
not working like it should be but don't
trip bluetooth's got you yeah maybe
you're a little stressed out
at home at work little performance
anxiety yeah well look don't trip
Bluetooth will make your dick rock hard
oh yeah that's right super hard uh all
you got to do is go to bluetooth.com use
the promo code bootleg that's boat leg
for you non-spelling [ __ ] out there use
that promo code they're gonna send you a
month's supply of Bluetooth for free
what is Bluetooth you ask well let me
tell you the same active ingredient as
Viagra anacialis
minus the awkward doctor's visits nobody
wants to go to a [ __ ] doctor's office
sit in line you're reading an old-time
Magazine from three years ago waiting
for your name to get caught you can go
in there and tell your doctor your dick
ain't working like it should be
nobody wants to do that nope but on
bluetooth.com it's all online they send
it right to your door discreet packaging
in a chewable form
look what are we talking about use the
promo code bootleg get a month for free
all you gotta do is pay five dollars in
shipping right and they just did their
Bluetooth mint chewable the same active
ingredient as Levitra
which is a little extra hitter you know
what I mean so fellas ladies Etc if you
need to you know get your dick right go
to bluetooth.com use that promo code
bootleg and try it for a month for free
free
what are we doing we're getting back to
the interview that's what we're doing
it's gonna happen
um now you obviously correct me if I'm
wrong I know you have songs with
quavo
offset did you ever do one with takeoff
no man unfortunately the last time
I spoke to take off it was at one of
these cookies events right and uh cuevo
had a strain drop so it was really
cuevo's event but takeoff was there too
right and I was you know in the back
chopping it out whatever we smoke one
I'm like take you the only me go I don't
have a record with yet you know what I'm
saying he's like I see what you're doing
bro come on you know I mean send me a
joint I'm like I got you and I [ __ ]
never did wow and it's really because a
lot of times I had a few of these
opportunities Nipsey too and I'll tell
you about that story but it was like
remember you know you think a lot of
times yeah you think you have time and I
was like I want the right record the one
thing about me is like I got a lot of
like amazing features blessed you know
what I mean but like
the compliment I'm getting for most
people is like yo you're using these
features on the right song for sure
right way you know what I mean I
remember I pressed play on a lot of
people
um and DJ head was at the studio of my
studio and I was playing him all the
joints and he was like yo I didn't
expect all this but then he said the
specific thing he's like yo I'm the most
impressive thing is like how you use
your features like you got the best out
of everybody you know what I'm saying so
yeah because some people will get a
feature and you'll be like why'd you put
this guy on an album cut right exactly
you know what I mean and that was my
thing because I understand it's a big
deal to get a song with these guys for
someone in my position you know what I
mean so you know and sometimes it takes
a little while to get that right one
every time I'm in the studio I'm like
would this one work for takeoff nah not
really let me you know what I mean and
then that [ __ ] happened man that [ __ ]
was crazy okay I drove by your store
like a week ago or two weeks ago is it
closed yeah no it's closed for
remodeling okay okay because I drove by
and I'm like everybody hitting did I
miss something the pentagon's closed I'm
like pentagon is open well it's not open
right now but you're remodeling because
I'm like I know you got Studio there I'm
like [ __ ] maybe he's moving I don't know
no no we in the back Studio [ __ ] is
everything is there but we're remodeling
right now we just kind of it was time to
revamp we've been there for like five
years just just the whole thing you know
new clothes new everything
um but yeah anything yeah I mean you
obviously have the weed uh the uh [ __ ]
it's a strain it's what's the strain's
name um well I dropped the first one was
lost Angel and then I dropped the strain
called yala Habibi which was kind of
limited see my thing is I really just
dropped strains with like music you know
it's like cross promotion I mean it's
great too and it's great weed you know
I'm tapped in with the right people as
far as that you are
um so you know well you know your people
know a thing or two about the weed
industry in here in California you know
what I'm saying my people uh yeah
they're doing amazing and they open so
many doors for me this whole wheat thing
opened the doors to all these artists
for me pretty much you know what I'm
saying yeah and uh do I just mean like
Armenians got this weird [ __ ] kind of
sewed up yeah no 100 strapses are
meteors and Asians it's not even kind of
the Asians yeah they run yeah well
backpack boys is Asian also we are
immediate of course
my people like literally my actual
people yes not my you know
um shout out my dogs
um yeah man the weed thing has been
amazing for me but I'm I'm like one foot
in one foot out as far as the wheat
business you know what I mean um I'm
trying to get any more but it's kind of
aren't you also like a a certified
pharmacist Yeah by trade yeah I am
and I own a pharmacy in Tarzana
um yeah man that's like the The
Immigrant Armenian thing is like man I
got my hands on some of that Joe Rogan
juice that was sold out everywhere
during the pandemic what was that [ __ ]
about oh I remember I grabbed some off
you oh yeah it's like yo you got that
Ivermectin [ __ ] I got you Doug yeah but
uh yeah please don't hit me for no
medication
um because people do all the time I bet
they do but they probably hit you for
some wild [ __ ] yeah they hit me for all
this [ __ ] that kind of [ __ ] is cool yeah
I got some antibiotics but like yo you
can't get perk 30s from me go [ __ ]
yourself yeah please um but I get that
all the time but yeah yeah I'm a
pharmacist too you know what I really I
went to school did all that um while I
was doing music and I realized this
ain't gonna work if I'm one foot and one
foot out you gotta go both feet in on
the rap [ __ ] man I fully went into music
but you know I have my license and I
have a amazing partner in the pharmacy
world you know I mean that kind of runs
the day-to-day that's amazing hey we got
to stop the interview real quick to tell
you about our family at hard Dean that's
right Jardine Las Vegas the craziest
dispensary in the world world the number
one dispensary in the United States let
alone in Las Vegas all right maybe
you're hitting Vegas with your friends
your girlfriends whatever maybe it's a
bachelor party whatever's going on
you're going to go watch the Raiders
suck [ __ ] whatever it is
make sure you pull up to Hardy in Las
Vegas tell them I sent you they got the
craziest selection of Premium cannabis
I've ever seen in my [ __ ] life the
pre-rolls the cartridges the Edibles the
flower all top notch all the best the
bud tenders are so friendly it smells
great it smells so good inside a Jardine
that they have their own Harding
signature scent candle
see I sniffed in I just think of Las
Vegas and picking up some amazing weed
all right so go follow them right now
Harding underscore Las Vegas shoot them
a follow get all the details you need
you can get you some of this fly ass
Jardine merch at hardinglasvegas.com
shout out to our family in Vegas I'm
excited too because coming up we're
going to be doing our very first podcast
from Jardin in Vegas with young gravy oh
yeah it's going down all right let's get
back to the interview all right so you
also uh I watched the Patrick David
podcast a lot oh yeah me too and you're
the uh you do the theme song yeah so
how'd that happen yeah um Patrick bad
Dave is a big supporter man so he's half
Armenian half Assyrian and he actually
um went to like high school with one of
my boys or whatever so years ago
um you know he was doing all these
videos on YouTube it was more like
um you know the business advice
motivation yeah before his podcast right
that's what kind of blew him up so my
boy hit me like yo this guy I used to
know whatever like he's be like check
them out and we really started watching
these videos and actually it was really
dope you know what I'm saying and then I
started following him on IG and [ __ ] and
then one day he did a post about hip-hop
and he's like my top five rappers of all
time right and he's like you know the
regular night you know he's in from the
90s probably he's like in his mid-40s so
he was like you know Tupac Nas Jay-Z
whatever and then in his caption he
wrote honorable mention my man armeen is
really dope you guys should check him
out and I'm like oh [ __ ] I don't know no
idea he knows me right
yeah and he even put the song like his
favorite song which was a song I did
with game a long time ago called Lost
Angels so you know then he followed me
back and everything and he was like yo
we support you we got you so he came by
my Store Pentagon when he was in LA then
when I went on tour with Berner
at that time he was in Texas he moved to
Florida I went over there to the
headquarters and then he came to the
show so he just really supportive you
know what I'm saying and then that's
when when we was in Texas he's like yo
maybe you can do like a song and we can
use it for like the YouTube videos at
the time it wasn't
um you know the podcast yet I'm like
hell yeah I had this like kind of
motivational joint called Sweet Victory
and I sent it to him they loved it they
started using it for their interviews
first you know he did the interviews
like he has a crazy interview with Kobe
um yeah I've been watching him for like
five or six years so I've been watching
him when he was in Texas when he was
doing all the inspirational [ __ ]
interviewing people yeah same as the
same as me so they used it just for
their for their interview section at
that time uh but a lot of big interviews
Kevin Hart Magic Johnson
even all the mobsters and [ __ ] yeah yeah
yeah yeah I heard um Vlad say that he
got the idea from valuetainment which
was Patrick that day you know what I'm
saying
um so yeah and then and then you know
the interview thing kind of stopped and
then just recently
they started using the same song for the
podcast so and automatically I see a
boost in the streams you know what I'm
saying like it pops up on my top five
all of a sudden now it's dope to see
because like he's somebody and what's
also dope is like any kind of like
Middle Eastern conflict [ __ ] going on or
even like the Azerbaijan Armenia thing
he does like a full like I really
educated myself on what's going on I ran
or what's going on in Armenia when he
puts those videos up absolutely and just
like I learned a lot from watching his
[ __ ] just everything you know I mean the
economy politics whatever like they you
know it might be a fan is like from all
walks of political absolutely the little
white dude he's with the comedian guys
like more liberal right you know what I
mean yeah yeah from all walks of life
and they just have like real honest
discussions you know what I mean yeah
it's my man shout out Patrick Bet David
bro hey we got to stop the interview to
tell you about our family at Odd Socks
that's right the most comfortable socks
in the [ __ ] world go to
oddsocksofficial.com right now use that
promo code bootleg and you'll save 20
off Christmas time is it coming and let
me tell you something their Black Friday
sale if you're watching this before
Black Friday you might be watching it
after Black Friday but if Black Friday
hasn't came yet just like Cyrus hasn't
came yet it's been a while he's on a
drought guess what oddsoxofficial.com
promo code bootleg 20 off plus whatever
the [ __ ] else is going on with their
Black Friday sale and let me tell you
they got some new licenses we got to
talk about boys
my particular favorites
one of the greatest shows of all time
they got the Beavis and butt heads you
know what I mean and this is really a
big deal
The Big Lebowski that's right the
greatest movie to ever exist
and shout out to all you rappers and
people who be pouring your lean into
this [ __ ] some Mountain Dew Baja
Blast socks
Casino great [ __ ] movie you know what
I mean these are pretty fly Bubblicious
yeah that's right a little Bubblicious
and this is the big one
big deal here
we got Coca-Cola socks baby that's right
Coke's on board
Coke is on board yeah I mean we get to
put the coke hat on
this hat doesn't work for me does it
doesn't work for me anyway you could get
you this hat though hey Cyrus take a
Coke hat there you go go to
oddsoxofficial.com use the promo code
bootleg right now save 20 off and go
purge their website for Black Friday get
gifts for your family your [ __ ]
family will love you if you buy them the
most comfortable socks in the world it's
that simple or you could buy them some
[ __ ] [ __ ] socks you could go buy
him some garbage ass [ __ ] ethica or
some [ __ ] ass [ __ ] Nike socks
[ __ ] them get Odd Socks let's get back
to the interview
um me and you have I would say pretty
similar taste in rap music what are your
favorite albums this year
of course kd-3 yeah
I really [ __ ] with the 21 Savage Drake
album her loss I agree stupid Doper than
I than I expected my top 10 for sure
yeah
um Kendrick of course yeah
your boy Freddie Gibbs is definitely in
the top five Triple S
um you know you know which one I really
like that I haven't heard people talk
about Montega
that was one album that I was listening
to a lot like no I mean like that should
definitely French albums
honestly those would probably be my top
five but I love the Joey Badass one of
course Pusha T
Usha T is always into how many years the
French album is definitely slept on
Harry Potter I mean Harry Fraud and 38
special just put out a crazy project
okay I haven't heard that one yet
LeBron's been posting it like every
other [ __ ] day really that's what's
up yeah I [ __ ] with 38 Special heavy
like as a fan no Harry Potter Beast no
but that's right you are right though
that French album is hard and nobody's
really [ __ ] get like I feel like it's
underrated bro super underrated like
French go hard on them hairy frog bees
bro that's French that's his sound yeah
that's what I think for sure
the [ __ ] hairy frog beats yeah man
he's a pop star and you know starts
[ __ ] Kardashians shout out to French
man legendary Hit List That French
Montana he's got a roster that's what
they say who he's like top five best
rosters in hip-hop Let's see we go
French who else is amazing Drake
obviously Drake's got a roster
Travis Nick Cannon Nick Cannon's got it
you know who Loki has a crazy roster I
don't know if it's Loki Scott Storage
yeah no my brother he's Loki and high
key and high key he's told me because
yeah Scott Storage will tell you stories
about girls he used to [ __ ]
and you'll be like oh you hit it first
yeah cause that [ __ ] was in the 2000s
Scott Storage was [ __ ] every [ __ ] in
the world before any like it's crazy
Scotty my brother I can't wait for him
to do a movie or like or a Netflix
series yeah I heard he did a deal with
50. he talked about it too oh Netflix
series I don't know our stars are just
about his life all the hoes he was
[ __ ] all the cocaine his whole story
is crazy it's insane shout out to
storage man uh all right well look your
tape comes out the 16th he said 16th
just incredible presents are mean uh
tapping with your boy yeah go running
around with be real is out right now
turn the music out a lot of music out a
lot of music out already but like a lot
of amazing music on the way like
honestly like I've never been this
confident you know what I'm saying like
like when I just said I've been pressing
play on people like I've never been this
confident to like Press Play in these
meetings so the now song will be on the
album of course yeah that's what I've
been kind of waiting for for an hour not
only for the album to be done but
honestly I've been kind of figuring out
how to release it that's why I had all
these listening sessions because
you know we talked about this a lot like
I had some meetings with major labels
too but that was never really to move uh
which Distribution Company to go with
even my immediate team not my immediate
day-to-day team but like you know what
I'm saying like the management or
whatever
um so I feel like everything is ready
now you know what I mean boom well we
rather have him rap so you guys could
check out the other YouTube video for
that you let's go all right my man thank
you for having me bro fire